-Here's what people
are talking about.
Some pretty big news
about the Russia investigation.
President Trump told reporters
that he is going to talk
to Robert Mueller, but he wants
to talk to him under oath.
Yeah. Then Trump turned
to his lawyers and said,
[ Imitating Trump ] "Relax,
I'll have my fingers crossed
the whole time."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Trump is willing to talk to
Robert Mueller under oath.
That will get off to a weird
start when Trump's told,
"Raise your right hand"
and he goes...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Imitating Trump ]
"My right or your right?"
Meanwhile,
the Justice Department recovered
50,000 missing text messages
from FBI agents. 50,000.
Yeah, and they were all from
just trying to set up
a group brunch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like...
"I can't make it then, man,
no way. My kid's got karate."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's actually in Switzerland
for the World Economic Forum
right now.
When someone asked him about
stake holders, Trump said...
[ Imitating Trump ]
"I believe the word is 'fork.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
This is pretty big. I read that
John Kerry is considering
running for President in 2020.
-Ooh.
Kerry has a great campaign
slogan.
"John Kerry:
Sorry I'm not Oprah."
-Wow.
[ Laughter and applause]
-Some TV news here. It was
announced that the '90s sitcom
"Murphy Brown" is coming back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right? Another revival.
You also have "Roseanne" on ABC,
"will & Grace" on NBC,
and "The Twilight Zone" on CNN.
And...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Speaking of comebacks, a pretty
big sports story here.
WWE chairman Vince McMahon
announced that he is
bringing back
his football league, the XFL.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
XFL fans were like, "what a day!
'Murphy Brown' and now this!
I'm, like, freakin' out, man!"
[ Applause ]
And get this, you guys. A man
broke a Guinness World Record
by walking barefoot on
a 120-foot path of loose LEGOs.
[ Laughter ]
This beats the old record set
by every dad getting up to use
the bathroom at night. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Groans ]
[ Applause ]
And finally,
this is pretty crazy.
I read that the actor who used
to play Barney the dinosaur now
runs a tantric sex business.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-I went back and watched some
old episodes of Barney,
and I think we should have seen
this coming.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-It always means a lot to me
to be with all my friends.
Each and every one of you is
a very special friend to me!
-♪♪ I wanna lick, lick, lick,
lick you ♪♪
♪♪ From your head to your toes ♪♪
♪♪ And I wanna move from the bed
down to the down ♪♪
♪♪ To the, to the floor ♪♪
-We have a great show tonight!
Give it up for the Roots!